hey guys Greg Alva here and John the
John of Justice I I'm still recovering
right now I feel a little bit better
took some medication some oral
medication take antibiotic sound cool
sound medical medication I don't wanna
like to try and peddle antibiotics to
kids feel like hey you want some it's
horrible I would never do that I know
you're on antibiotics what the hell are
you talking about in terms of reference
to me right now Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles out of the shadows official
trailer number two in that playbook
Halloween Dre bro the one night of the
year it in
in fact it what part move in the shadows
don't you understand
yes
oh I've never seen anything like this
before
guys I got a lead on what's going on
since I saw this one up was Bill you
know Souris and you're I'm a little
piggy Casey Jones you do guys like a
thing if the purple ooze can turn humans
into animals
into humans we don't have to be stuck
down here forever if there's that make
us human or Turtles whether you like it
or not and we're brief who you are
we keep failing
keep the team unified and you shall
always succeed
wait a month
boy
don't forget me now
all right
Wow I don't know you know can you pull
up the IMD oh you cuz there's some names
I can't remember right now
Wow five producer names on the others
this is a very strange time okay I don't
see going to happen to be it not good
thanks man all right and Darla we can't
operate unless we got IMDB up I'm sorry
yeah but then we gotta cut out the part
we'll be talking about INDD because
people gonna be like damn they don't
know all these facts off the top of
their heads